hello and welcome to this ai coffee
break
this time we will discuss a very
important phenomenon
in our world reflection but
most importantly we will see how this
paper
entitled visual chirality analyzes
mirroring images when training deep
neural networks and how this
can affect how these algorithms are
trained to perceive
our visual reality but first a
little introduction of the notions of
chirality
and data augmentation if you are an
expert on these topics already
feel free to skip to the next chapter in
the video
so let's start with chirality every
human has
experienced what mirroring is perhaps
the first time as a baby
looking into a mirror physicists and
mathematicians understand this
phenomenon pretty well
and can describe it formally to reflect
this image of a face
everything one needs to do is to
multiply all coordinates by
almost an identity matrix almost because
the reflection matrix has a catch
a minus for the x dimension does making
the image go
the other way with neural networks
processing images the way they handle
reflections
is very different especially for
classical image processing architectures
like the convolutional neural network or
short
cnn but first we need to understand
convolutions
the convolution operation does something
similar to what happens in our
eyes it bundles information from image
regions together
learning parameters that determine how
exactly to sum this information
up in this architecture convolutions
ensure the so called shift invariance
meaning that if we have the same pattern
or object
at a different position in the image
like this blue shape
here the response will not change
because the aggregating parameters stay
the same by construction
this makes sense as we want to detect a
dog independently of its exact position
in the image
so in this case of a convolutional
architecture no other parameters are
learnt when shifting
but something very different happens
when the image is mirrored
convolutional neural networks are not
invariant to reflections
this is because convolutions are very
sensitive to ordering
and the parameter learned for field
number four
is not a sensible parameter when applied
to the mirrored version anymore
this means that the network has to learn
one set of parameters when presented
with an image
and a different set of parameters if
presented with the same image
but mirrored so while convolutions are
specifically built to handle translation
of the objects through the image very
well
there is nothing intrinsic to the
network telling it the connection
between the mirrored and the
non-mirrored
version of an image but this however has
the following implication
if the cnn has to learn different
parameters for the image and for the
mirrored version
it means that the network can do useful
parameter updates
from both versions and because more
training data is
always a good bet for deep learning
researchers
thought if we mirror images we can
double our training set
if we mirror on the other axis we have
now
four times as many images and of course
this does not make sense for some kind
of images that have a preference for the
sky
to stay upwards but anyway here it is
reflection one way to do data
augmentation and it is cool
or this is the state where this paper
here came
in to scold us all a little bit because
we were so busy augmenting the data sets
with reflected images
that we did not think about how this
might impact the statistics in the data
and how we know machine learning is all
about fitting the data in very many
different ways
from linear regression to deep neural
models
so surprise surprise if we change the
data distribution by mirroring
our super duper fitting machine might
notice that
so how can we detect mirroring with a
neural network
if mirroring happened we as humans can
detect it
thanks to special objects with the
chiral property
take for example a left hand if we
mirror it
we have a right hand but if we try to
overlap it with the original
we cannot unless we mirror this
reflection again
these special objects that help us
humans detect mirroring
are called chiral in the geometrical
sense
but can computer vision models detect
this chirality too
well it seems they can to prove this the
authors define the concept of visual
chirality
because what holds for geometric
chirality does not necessarily hold for
images
take the example of a left hand if
mirrored it might be as well a right
hand in an image
it would not necessarily mean that the
image has been flipped
so instead the authors start with
defining visual
i chirality if we want to estimate the
distribution d
of x where x is our data it might be
for example the images we usually
perform data augmentation
by applying a transformation t to the
data x
this transformation could be the
reflection for example
for i chiral data this equation here
would hold
meaning that there would be no
difference of the distribution of the
data before
and after the transformation then the
degree
in which an image x would violate this
equation
is a measure for visual chirality
so to recapitulate a human hand would be
geometrically chiral but not visually
chiral
but what would be visual chiral then
well
clocks text but also let's not spoil
everything and let the neural network
show us what it looks at to tell
mirrored images apart from
non-mirrored ones for this the authors
train
a widely used cnn a resnet to classify
reflected from non-reflected images
and the network gets pretty good at it
reaching accuracies up to 90
when testing on the test subset of the
instagram data set
when being applied to other images a
little out of domain
it still performs better than random
chance at telling mirrored images from
non-mirrored
images apart they also visualize the
discriminative regions of the image
giving us a hint at what the network is
focusing on
when giving the answer it looks at
smartphones it watches
shirt colors and pockets but also
they show that chirality is present in
face
images too on the applied ffhq data set
here seems to be a hint for chirality
because the pictures
imply that the majority of people part
their hair
from left to right also gaze is a hint
for chirality suggesting a bias
in gaze direction possibly because of
ocular dominance
these are high level features that give
away the visual chirality of the image
even more interestingly the authors also
detect
low-level chiral cues they are artifacts
from image processing steps like
compression
i look at you jpeg and make the images
chiral these effects are imperceptible
to humans
but this is something that the neural
network could capture
so all this time we were using image
reflection for data augmentation in
computer vision and
not many of us were looking at the
subtleties like this paper does
this is my favorite kind of paper it has
a lot of insight
gained with a very simple idea and it
was always lurking in the mirror
when we were not looking great job
if you like this paper at least as much
as the coffee bean does
check out the link in the description
below if you like this video do not
forget to hit the like and subscribe at
hands
and let me know in the comments what
topic you want miss coffee bean to
explain next
[Music]
you